you talk to people who are expert
completer users they are so bloody
powerful it is just beyond belief try to
pull the company and have it succeed is
like eating glass and staring into the
abyss every morning I go for a run
that's the first thing I do every
morning haven't taken a day off of
running since December 2016 wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back it lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the ten universal
skills that are hard to learn but will
pay off forever
okay let's kick it off with skill number
one develop a high pain tolerance with
Elon Musk there's a friend of mine has
got a great saying about creating a
company which is creating turnable the
company and have it succeed is like
eating glass and staring into the abyss
so you know what tends to happen is it's
sort of quite exciting for the first
several months of starting a company and
then then reality sets in things don't
go as well as planned customers aren't
signing up the technology of the park
isn't working as well as you thought and
and then can that concerns be compounded
by a recession and it can be very very
painful for several years so I think
frankly starting a company you know I
would advise people to have a high pain
tolerance skill number to master
computer skills with Jordan Peterson I
made a decision when the computers
started to become omnipresent and so
that would have been about 1993 that I
was going to spend a year and that was
the first year that I was teaching in
Boston pretty much doing nothing but
figuring out how Intel 486 has worked
and it meant there was a lot of other
things that I had to put on hold but I
did become a competent
computer user and I was I'm pretty fast
but you know my son it's just annoying
as hell to watch him on the computer and
on the phone because and my graduate
students as well because there's so much
faster than me that it's not even funny
and I'm not really accustomed to being
slower than someone else in the room and
so now if I had children now the one
thing I would bloody well make sure that
they knew was how to use a computer how
to program man because if you're smart
and you can use a computer you are so
much smarter than you are if you're just
smart that it's not even funny
you know and you talk to people it's in
Silicon Valley all the time you talk to
people who are expert computer users
they are so bloody powerful it is just
beyond belief so and that that's gonna
do nothing but expand right because
Moore's law is not dead and computers
are doubling in power every 18 months
and and so and who the hell knows where
that's going to go still number three
become a learning machine with Tony
Robbins well you can you don't have a
standard education and expect to have an
extraordinary life it's not gonna happen
the one breakthrough for all leaders is
constant never-ending improvement and
that means educating yourself and
continuing to develop even greater
emotional mastery because that's what
affects whether you execute enough the
opportunity for self education is there
we have to change our psychology from
I'm gonna do what everybody else does
and I'm mad because it doesn't work
anymore to the reality is this the
greatest time to be alive if you're
growing you're learning you're educating
and you're developing valuable skills
it's like if you go to work for
McDonald's I don't know I think the
average I read recently is seven dollars
and 75 cents an hour in the United
States working for McDonald's the skill
sets the value you provide can be taught
to anyone in about 20 minutes instead of
complaining you gotta say where are the
skill sets valued in the marketplace and
how do I work harder on myself than
anything else because if I become
more valuable then I will be able to
give more do more and change more I
interviewed Warren Buffett ask the most
important best man he ever made in his
life he already said it was I was
thinking all the companies they've done
you know he said Tony going to Dale
Carnegie said what he goes because by
developing myself that's the most
important investment those skill sets
learning how to persuade learning how to
speak learning and influence all my
ideas would've died on my lips if I
hadn't be able to influence and I
learned it from that little course most
valuable thing ever in my life he said
skill number four influence and persuade
people with IDI pilot if I could go back
and you could only give me one skill to
begin with and I had to build from all
of it
I can tell you for sure what it would be
for me and that would be the ability to
influence so it's the ability to
persuade people without that skillset
the vast majority of my wealth does not
exist if you can't persuade people
if you can't influence people to make
decisions that are in their own best
interest but that also grow your
business your brand your company your
net worth
you can't ever become successful one
thing that everybody I know that's a
leader and everything they do can do is
persuade people no I watch people do
that in all different types of ways some
do it through intimidation some through
do it through force some do it through
humor so I'm do it through persuasive
strategies transfer of energy you name
it but all leaders can persuade all
successful people can get people to make
decisions on their own best interests
that also get them to participate with
their company it's the number one skill
that I see most people not spending the
most time on is their ability to
communicate their ability to persuade
people and because they're constantly
trying to go to a different course or
they think that somehow if their product
is good enough or they get the right
sales pitch that somehow they're gonna
win but the fact of the matter is you've
got to become a better person
also if you want to have more confidence
and motivation check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join our
description
there are times when if something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do you do it in spite of the
fear you've got to separate the vehicle
from the outcome what is it that's gonna
truly fulfill you what is it that's
gonna give you that extraordinary life
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today skill
number five have integrity with Warren
Buffett it takes three qualities
essentially to do well and extremely
well actually in this country it takes
intelligence it takes energy and it
takes integrity and I say if you don't
have integrity you know we don't want to
hire somebody that's got intelligence
and energy if they don't have integrity
we'd rather hire somebody that's dumb
and lazy if they don't have integrity
because they probably never get around
to cheating us or doing something and
integrity is absolutely an option you
know you may not be able to throw
football 60 yards and you know you may
not be able to run the hundred and nine
eight you know you may not be able to
sneak free pointers from but you can
choose where you stand on the integrity
scale can't you weren't born wired one
way or the other there's an absolute
choice you make still number six develop
discipline with David Guardians I
prioritize
trying to win the battle in the morning
so I always win the battle of mourning
so I get morning time every morning I go
for a run that's the first thing I do
every morning haven't taken a day off of
running since December 2016 I've every
day up in the morning so I also stretch
out every day for about two or three
hours every day I've missed two days and
about five and a half six years so
that's just my routine in about four
days a week I'm in the gym hitting the
weights because you know you can't just
be a runner so this is every single day
the the monotony of my life but this is
what builds discipline you know and not
everybody I'm not telling everybody to
do this but this is my lifestyle this is
how I build self-discipline still number
seven be a great reader with Oprah
Winfrey and I would say reading is the
strongest signal for success in the
future that I've ever seen
it is the strongest strongest strongest
I got my first job in radio when I was
16 years old because I've been in
broadcasting since I was 16 years old
but my first job I got because I was a
great reader when you are a great reader
you can articulate and speak and command
the English language in ways that other
people cannot and people think you're a
lot smarter than you are
lots of times because you're great
reader have you ever met a person who
was a great reader when they were young
who was not successful you never never
it is the absolute best foundation ever
in life skill number eight don't over
value your time with Gary Vaynerchuk how
do you know when a business opportunity
or venture is worth your time and when
do you say no when so many people would
say yes in that situation I think too
many people over value their time when
their time is worth nothing so this is
my favorite one like I love when I love
when people like yo is this worth my
time I'm like well well and it's in a
business context I'm like well how much
money is your business making they're
like yo I don't have one yet I'm like
well your time is worth zero so I think
people are people are audacious with
their time their fancy before their
fancy so everything is worth your time
when you're at zero
you may bail I'm a big believer of going
I'm in yes culture my whole game is yes
, I'm not a great person to ask the know
thing I think there's people that are
more disciplined that know I just like
the value of yes and then if I'm a week
an hour a year in and I realized it's
not right
I leave I bail because I'm not worried
about the loss because I'm not hearing
anybody's opinions I think every I think
you get context you know the reason I
like starting up and stopping businesses
is because I like the context like right
now I'm super hot on this thesis that
sports trading cards are about to
explode again so I'm spending on a godly
amount of me like I spent four and a
half hours
looking at qualitative data and quant
data on eBay around giannis rookie cards
from prism graded PSA 10 four and a half
hours I don't have like three minutes
for people that are running like ten
million dollar businesses for me so I
like saying yes because I know I'm
learning things and then if I decide
it's not worth it
I'll bounce so a couple things I would
tell you is one we need less audacity
right and we need more tasting and so
and the and I know when it's time to say
no after I've said yes and realize that
they're tasting it it's no you know many
people hate oysters but I've never had
one that's how I think about that
question still number nine don't waste
money with Mark Cuban way we ran our
business
it was just like lean and mean right you
invest in your product you invest in
your customers you invest in your people
and you know we had open offices you
don't need fancy stuff they immediately
came down and just we did all the
furniture and purple and gold I'm like
it's cool that's my high school's colors
you know but why are we spending this
money got a whole new office a whole new
building you know I'm just like why are
we spending this money one of the things
in my rules right when I look at
companies to invest in if someone walks
in was swag here's my coffee mug with my
logo
here's your t-shirt with my logo I don't
see anybody wearing a t-shirt with a
startups logo do you know would you wear
some other startups logo polo shirt
hell no hell no right it's just a waste
of money you know put your money where
you're able to differentiate yourself
and add value that set separate yourself
so you can get ahead don't waste it and
skill number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus one is develop your
communication skills with Grant Cardone
well I think the the idea of
not going to endorse you know talking to
people yeah like these are the skills
that are not taught in the schools this
is why it goes back to your question
about the school system failing the bake
that the the required skills I need a
client like if you simplify the thing
that people like about what we do is we
simplify the business process mm-hmm I
need to make a contact how can I do that
like how can I just simply if I'm doing
if I'm a cameraman and I want more work
you know how do I knock on the door or
make a phone call get in front of
someone so hard impress them you know if
I go to Harrods right here I'll see how
many people don't have that skill I walk
in that I don't even get a Hello you
know I don't get hello how you doing
great to have you here appreciate you
being here it's so nice of you to drop
by
thanks for coming into Cartier I mean
it's it's a three million dollar ring
over there I went in there the other day
I can't even get anybody to show me
anything I'm like how much is the ring
you know they kind of looked at me right
can you show it to me do you mind
showing it to me
he showed it to me tell me how much it
was and I'll leave you didn't show me a
second ring a third ring unfortunately
so those are the skills that people need
right how do i how do i interact with
people communicate yeah now I have a
special bonus tip from Barack Obama on
how to become charismatic that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
video to taking action here we go
question number one what will you do
this week to improve your communication
skills number two where do you need to
stop wasting money and number three what
new book can you pick up and start
reading today and if you're still here
watching this video I want to celebrate
you give me a hashtag believe in the
comments as well you may have heard
about this Kanye is thinking about
running
for Speaker of the House
it couldn't get any stranger but in case
Kanye is serious about this whole POTUS
thing or as he calls it peasy
[Music]
I do have advice for there's some stuff
that I picked up on the way first of all
you've got to spend a lot of time
dealing with some strange characters who
behave like they're on a reality TV show
so you gotta be cool with that love you
too second second this is the second
important tip saying that you have a
beautiful dark twisted fantasy that's
what's known as off message in politics
you can't say something like that a lot
of people who have lost the
congressional seat same things like that
you don't do that that's number two and
number three do you really think that
this country is gonna elect a black guy
from the southside of Chicago with a
funny name to be prison in the United
States
if you want to learn how billionaires
think check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
what are you urging them to do I'll
explain guess what I'm talking about